citizens of the reject nation welcome to
koi's comic corner a very special
she-hulk centric episode we are talking
about the cameos we could see in
she-hulk now there's been a lot of hopes
there's been a lot of rumors it's also
very logical to bring in a bevy of new
characters in a lobby show with cheok
having so many super heroic friends and
recently one of the writers said about
season one and i quote there will be a
lot of fun a lot of cameos and a lot of
characters that have never existed in
the mcu before that we're pulling out of
the comic books you know how much that
excites me now before we get into it
please do leave a like helps us out very
much please do share this video leave a
comment like subscribe hit that bell all
the other youtube things and most
importantly for me leave a comment
letting me know what you want to see
more of let me know what other videos
you'd like and thank you i'd just like
to thank you for checking out my tic toc
a number of you have found my tick tock
it is largely what i'm doing here but in
short form 15 second to three minute
bursts of comic book knowledge coming at
you now let's get into she-hulk
[Music]
now hulk abomination and wong are not
cameos they look to be all over this
show they're not gonna make this list
because they look to be full-on
supporting characters so we're not gonna
consider those cameos and like i said at
the top this is a show dealing with the
first super heroic lawyer she's gonna be
defending superhero she's gonna be
meeting superheroes this is the pitch
perfect way to bring in a lot of
characters so let's talk about who they
might be number one daredevil now this
could be a full-on guest star this could
be a full-on supporting character but
right now we're gonna call it a cameo we
did have a beautiful moment in that
newest footage where we do have
daredevil fully clad in his suit and in
the comic books daredevil and jennifer
walters are friends and tatiana mislani
confirmed that it is in fact how they're
going to be in this show but we could
have she-hulk and daredevil fighting
because we don't know which side of
things they're going to land on now matt
murdock is obviously a lawyer so i'd be
excited to see if matt murdock faces off
against jennifer walters and daredevil
faces off against she-hulk and we have
that fun in and out of the office
dynamic with these characters we've seen
there's a comedic tone to this show it
would be interesting if maybe she
doesn't know matt murdock is daredevil
at the top and we've got that conflict
it's a very classic comic book conflict
and i think going forward it's very
smart to establish what matt murdock's
line in the sand is what that's going to
be going into his 18 episode show in the
future i'm hoping this is a bit more
than just a throwaway cameo i hope he
does more than catch a brick and say
he's a very good lawyer no matter how
much daredevil we get i want all of it
on to number two number two and one of
the biggest rumors that i have no idea
if it's true or not but it's so big i'm
excited ben grimm's the thing now ben
grimm might need a lawyer ben grimm
might just be walking by and break
something i'm imagining that idea of
damage control by way of lawyer not the
department of damage control that's a
different thing in the mcu but actually
causing damage just by existing if
anyone's gonna break stuff by walking
through new york or any major city it's
the thing it's been grim we've heard for
some time that we're gonna have the
fantastic four already established that
movie we've just had confirmed is not an
origin movie what better way to
incorporate the fantastic four than by
sprinkling in characters in fun comedic
ways and building to their solo movie
just like with the avengers we had
hawkeye and thor we had all these
characters kind of sprinkled in i think
it's very smart to have ben grimm
introduced with jennifer walters and
there does look to be an element of
jennifer walters feeling self-conscious
about her being the hulk her her feeling
not quite herself green and six foot
seven there could be a great
conversation between the thing accepting
how he looks and coming to terms that as
well as she'll i'd love if there was an
element of the thing in her bonding over
embracing their appearance and embracing
who they are now and i'd love if that
was the dynamic they have in the show if
ben grimm's in it at all this just in we
are getting confirmation that johnny
blaze i'm sorry donnie donnie blaze is
it there is a ghost rider rumor that's
been going around for a long time greg
made a video out of it we're gonna find
out how true that is i'm very excited
and hopeful there does appear to be a
something blaze and there does appear to
be a blaze behind him this might be the
ghost rider cameo been rumored to have
this might be any of the number of
actors we've had kind of bandied about
and again we're leading towards the
midnight suns we are getting blade very
soon we are having more and more
supernatural elements especially after
the multiverse of madness we've gone
into this world of the underbelly
mephistos coming but we don't know how
far they're gonna go i think it's very
smart if they are going to start
introducing these differently toned
characters to do it in a fun way you can
really mess up ghost rider it's a fun
way to introduce him in shilk and i
think a smart way i'm very very much
hoping it's norman reedus number four is
three characters it's kind of cheating
and that's okay returning netflix
characters jessica jones and luke cage i
think as a couple and because they are
very very close friends in the comics
hellcat patsy walker now hellcat and
jennifer walters are rider dies they're
besties so are jessica jones and
jennifer walters and i do honestly think
this would be a really fun way to bring
in luke cage and hopefully child of
jessica jones and luke cage i would love
to see jessica and luca's parents i
would love to have that family dynamic
especially juxtaposing jennifer walters
on tinder i think it'd be really fun as
we've seen the dating elements of the
show if you've got that one friend
that's still dating and you've got the
other friends that are like married with
kids when you hit a certain age internet
there comes a time where you're the last
single friend all your friends are
buying houses and married and no it's
not sad it's very fun i hope that's luke
cage and jessica jones dynamic and i
also would love if we get to see some
hellcat i think you can really usher in
the entire netflix universe in this show
and that brings me to number five i also
think number five as a twofer is going
to potentially be colleen wing and maybe
even foggy nelson if you've got matt
murdock you've got some lawyers maybe
you don't want to have too much matt
murdock because you're leading to the
daredevil show maybe you don't have
daredevil element it might work to have
some really fun foggy stuff i really
like how they used foggy in the
daredevil show because he didn't feel
like he was pushed aside foggy is the
heart of what matt murdock represents he
keeps him centered it could be fun if
jennifer walters is torn and she doesn't
know what to do with the case and foggy
is also her guiding light i think it'd
be a fun dynamic and then as far as
colleen wing this is a leap it's a
stretch but i do feel like iron fist
wasn't exactly beloved in the netflix
universe it'd be cool if they were able
to incorporate elements of that show
that did work and jessica henwick
definitely worked i'd love if maybe she
became iron fist we'll see but those are
my theories number six red hulk now this
one's tricky because we did just lose
the actor who played thunderbolt ross
william hurt and that does complicate
things but that is a very integral
character to the greater mcu thunderbolt
ross isn't the reason they named it
thunderbolts but in other
interpretations thunderbolt ross leads
the thunderbolts i know it's confusing i
do think that he's important to the
greater saga of hulk and therefore to
she-hulk i don't know how much they're
gonna be incorporating hulk's rogues but
we're gonna talk about a few more
characters later that might come into
play but i do know that hulk and
abomination tie directly into she-hulk
here that's how she-hulk gets her powers
it looks like abominations her first
client i do think they're tying this
pretty heavily into both the mark
ruffalo and the edward norton hulks so i
would love if we get a red hulk i would
love we see the variety of hulks come to
play i would love that's an evolution of
both her character and where we go with
the thunderbolts i just don't know how
they do that respect william hurt if
they do go that way i think recasting
versus reanimating with cgi or have him
be stuck as the red hulk have the
mustache have that uncanny valley just
keep it as the red hole or it is
possible that they did already shoot
some stuff before he passed away they
might be able to use some footage where
they have him as the human element of
thunderbolt before he transforms into
the red hole or you cast ed harris maybe
ed harris number seven modok we're gonna
get weird we're gonna get into those
characters here we are now this is a
machine designed only for killing what
if that machine designed only for
killing comes into the courtroom like
jennifer walters please represent me i
i'm a machine designer for this i was
designed to kill i can't control my
instincts what if she has to defend
something that was made to kill that
doesn't feel like he has a choice
obviously we know modoc has a choice
also on the other side he's very closely
tied to aim now aim is advanced idea
mechanics this is a giant super villain
conglomerate of mad scientists they wear
bee
keeper masks hats big yellow suits
they're ridiculous they were briefly
mentioned in iron man 3 but they weren't
this full super villainy quite yet that
said they are very important to the
video game as is modoc there's an
avengers game that isn't this continuity
but is using elements of things i think
the mcu is going to use i could see
modoc being an element of advanced idea
mechanics that could then tie into
ant-man and the wasp quantomania i do
feel like aim would suit that world or
jennifer walters in future seasons going
up against giant evil corporations as
things escalate i could see all this
happen number eight going from modoc to
betty ross that's the way lists go
sometimes i could see liv tyler coming
back we did see in what if where they
used the hulk cannon from before mark
ruffalo was hulk we did see ed norton's
hulk utilized in what if that could be
kind of reminding people and laying the
groundwork again for livetight this is
very much a family story jennifer
walters is bruce banner's cousin that
blood transfusion is how all of this
occurred i could see maybe this being
the way they have more screen time to
allow for liv tyler to come back as
we've had it now we haven't really had a
hulk solo movie because there were
rights issues universal owns the hulk or
did own the hulk now he's coming back
but there's issues between single and t
it's a whole thing you don't need to get
into it it's a lot of law that being
said it isn't applying to a she-hulk
show what they're allowed to do and this
long form format would be a great way to
tie up more continuity from the ed
norton era maybe bringing us liv tyler
and liv well betty betty and jenny are
friends so hopefully that works out i'd
love to see liv tyler come back number
nine the most important character on
this list a character we've dreamed of
since thanos first turned around and
smiled a character i've wanted to see on
screen since i was a young man a
character that rivals spider-man in his
that's a slightly gross animal mixed
with man in title alone characteristics
a character that is so ripe with super
villainy that he's going to leap into
our hearts and make us quake in our
froggy boots frog man is coming and
frogman is going to be ridiculous i
don't know if they're going to call him
leapfrog i don't know if they're going
to call him frogman i don't know what's
going to happen he's in the trailer i
hope he's someone she defends frogman
number nine i just i just want to talk
about frogman not even kidding number 10
the secret invasion is coming number 10
a lot of people are going to be trying
to figure out who is good who is evil in
a courtroom what if one of those people
is a shape-shifter what if one of those
people is a super scroll what if we got
the super scrolls here laying some
groundwork for a fantastic four what if
we got what does it mean when you're
talking to someone and they can
literally transform what's the legality
behind that i would love to see some
metamorphosizing i would love to see a
big green alien with the different limbs
of the fantastic four the super
squirrels have been around since the 60s
the super scroll leadership would be a
fascinating commentary leading into
secret invasion i'm very hopeful at some
point maybe not here but in the near
future we get a super scroll i think
it's possible here number 11 one of the
great characters in the hulk mythos is
his father a lot of the rage that hulk
feels which is obviously very important
hulk is towards his father his father
abused him his father was a monster the
immortal hulk comic is gonna be my
recommendation for this whole video go
read a mortal hulk there's a lot of
stuff with bruce versus his father and i
really think that maybe if they're
dealing with the family elements of
jennifer and bruce and their dynamic
maybe they'll get into the origin of
hope maybe they'll tie everything back
to what makes him angry and made him so
incapable of controlling his stuff
versus jennifer walters able to control
it she breaks the fourth wall she stays
the hulk but can still speak and serve
law she's got it under control why
didn't hulk because of his father it'd
be an interesting dynamic and would add
some depth to the show and it would add
some really interesting and honestly
kind of therapeutic elements to phase
four which has been the therapy season
so let's see if they do it i kind of
want some hulk dad number 12 i really
want the wrecking crew i think they're
coming i can almost guarantee they're
coming now these guys are uh you know
four like pal driver they're a
ridiculous set of team here and they've
been around since the 60s the wrecking
crew has fought spider-man they've
thought thor they've fought hulk they
fought she-hulk but i could see them
maybe being a team that she has to
defend i could see them maybe getting
into some problems and this being a way
to bring in a ridiculous stan lee steve
ditko kirby era set of villains we
haven't seen in the mcu before as a way
to be like yeah we know they're a
one-note joke but this is going to
endear us to them i think we might and i
likely i'd put money on the wrecking
crew and i would say jennifer walters
defending them would make comic fans
happy and it would also be a great way
to show how ridiculous things can go in
the law side of the mcu number 13 jack
of hearts now this character's relation
to she-hulk is far too long to get into
and he's a really weird hybrid he's
human he's half contraction he's a whole
thing but at one point in the comic
books he's responsible for killing
jennifer walters he's responsible for
de-powering her he accidentally ends the
life of jennifer walters this character
has a really iconic imagery he's half
dark half light he's got a lot of card
iconography but i do think bringing him
into this and having him as maybe
someone jennifer walters dates or
someone that cause he's of hearts he's
got this whole charm bravado about him
and then comic fans would be like oh
that's important to she-hulk later but
also in the dating i do want to see some
meta-human dating i don't want jennifer
walters to only date the guys we've seen
in the trailer i think it'd be fun in a
speed dating montage or even going on a
date if she gets to date someone those
powers maybe matt murdock but maybe jack
of hearts let's get after it at a human
bone number 14 jazenda now this is not a
super scroll she's a regular scroll but
she has a lot of ties to jennifer
walters in the comic books and she's
someone that's working against the
scroll she's she's good for lack of a
better term to not be so nuanced about
good and evil but she's a good skrull i
would love if we start laying elements
leading up to secret invasion of skrulls
that have our interests at heart as of
right now in captain marvel most of the
skrulls we've seen are on our side but i
don't think that's gonna last very long
i'd like to see a few more scrolls we
meet now that way when the secret
invasion happens and there's a lot of
conflict maybe also when we get the
marvels and we've got this pre-scroll
war to come i'd like to have a lot more
scrolls established so i'd like to see
jazenda and i do honestly think to be a
great place to bring her in these last
three are for me and my lucky numbers 15
these the ones i want most 15 amadeus
cho the totally awesome hulk our newest
hulk in the comic books is a young super
scientist that's able to stay in control
but also is one of the smartest people
on the planet and is the strongest one
there is he's a really fun take on the
hulk he's a young hip he's a champion
but what he does is he kind of allows
for the young avengers to have a hulk he
kind of allows there to be a new
generation of like willingness power set
so i'd love if we've got professor hulk
she-hulk they're professionals they got
jobs what if we get a totally awesome
hulk and he's this rad kid amadeus cho i
think we're leading towards young
avengers and i think any good team needs
a hulk gimme amadeus cho even as a cameo
even as the human element of him that
will one day later transform i just as a
nerd i need that easter egg i was
thinking do i want to say the big wheel
do i want to say paste pop pete do i
want to say rocket racer what
preposterous character arm falloff guy
who do i want that is the most
ridiculous villain to make frogman look
possible i'm going stilt man i want
stiltman in here so bad because he's a
dude that steals by inventing a stilt
suit he literally lifts hundreds of feet
in the air and has long stilty arms any
steel stuff and i want to see stiltman
for one scene in his little contracted
suit or wreaking havoc in a town and
someone have to defend him in the court
of law and i love that stiltman has been
around since the 60s i love that there's
a lady stilt man you heard me lady stilt
man and i love the fact that this
character has endured and it's about
time the mcu respects the stilts number
17 and my last maybe there's plenty of
other options again this could have been
45 long but greg is like coy no one's
gonna watch that but you and i was like
that's true but one i think will be
coming because of the villain in this
show titania often dates absorbing man
victor creel is absorbing man and he's a
very fun character cause he's able to
literally touch things absorb them and
wield their power he's fought thor and
hulk to sandstills he's a very powerful
character when he wants to be and i
think it'd be really interesting he also
has history with matt murdock's dad uh
so i think it'd be really interesting if
we've got the daredevil elements
incorporated into the super villain
elements and then you start to see that
these characters relate to both the
civilian identities and the superhero
identities which is what this show is
gonna be about as of the mcu today we've
had a lot of separation of super
identity and regular identity everyone
kind of knows who these characters are
right like other than spider-man and
daredevil pretty much everyone's
unmasked in the mcu we haven't had the
opportunity to show the conflict between
civilian and superhero i think that's
what she-hulk is going to introduce very
strongly in the mcu where miss marvel
was able to introduce the word mutants
and introduce a world that hates and
fears them i think she-hulk's gonna
start to represent the idea of dual
identities and how those kind of differ
i think a great way to do that is
absorbing man he's got history at
daredevil as a civilian and he's got
history with these people as heroes and
i think that's gonna be a really fun
thing and he's dating a super villain so
i'd put some money on absorbing man i
think he's coming i think it's a fun way
to bring him in and i think it sets up a
lot of the themes we're gonna get with
she-hulk
his name is carl creel god damn i was
victor creel's uh stranger things you
know what happens when you're uh you're
a you're a [ __ ] idiot i just got
fired
this is the last koi's comic corner this
is uh guys it's been a pleasure
i enjoy stranger things more than marvel
i guess
i've failed this city carl creel with a
cameo by greg carl creel's coming you
lovelies i appreciate you all very very
much please do leave a comment let me
know what more you want to hear about
let me know other things you'd like to
see a video about let me know how
excited you are for she-hulk and please
do again check out my tick tock and most
importantly
go read a carl creel comic
see you next week or tomorrow who knows
when
[Music]